[Applause]
[Music]
konban talk with the king fight his head
boy Saturday March 16 oh oh boy Aroldis
truth Spence jr. vs Mikey blackhat
Garcia so you know Mackay has come up
for different weight classes its
conquered four different weight classes
and he's coming up he facing the
unsurmountable challenge of the
juggernaut the truth the reason why
people call people to truth man remember
when um when it was calling this guy the
truth they played for Boston
man he was nice a shout out to real
boxing man this is what you're talking
about two undefeated champions going at
each other somebody owns got to go so
you know 100% these dudes just coming in
they don't know how to lose they don't
know how to lay down they don't know how
to take a back seat
both these dudes is walking in and they
eyes is champion there's only one true
champion in that ring cuz they fighting
for Spencer's belt but at no point in
time there's either one of them lesser
than when it comes to stature now coming
up into this fight you know you had a
lot of questions you like what the hell
is Mike you gonna say even thinking
about fighting this dude this dude is in
his prime he's a champion he's strong as
a heavy hitter he breaks opponents down
why he's Mikey going up there well Mikey
fought Brona so he said that's one big
dude I gotta beat I can get in there and
mix it up I don't really want to waste
too much time on on the fake factual's
man and pointing our stuff that you just
you just not gonna see
listen you will see two great fighters
in the ring Saturday night the weigh-in
came in they both made weight easy well
you know Mikey was gonna make weight cuz
he was coming up so let's see he just
ate fatty foods there was no way for him
to not make weight he came in two pounds
under the weight well actually three
pounds under the weight of 147 he came
in at what does that 144 little light
but you know how big is he gonna really
get you understand so then you got
Spence who came in a 146 and a half
that's letting you know old boy took
this so seriously it's crazy I'm not
gonna get into the box on politics of it
I'm not gonna get into the level of
disrespect that you have older fighters
not supporting fighters I tend to see
that a lot in the USA we don't support
our USA bred fighters
Errol Spence is olympian he represented
the United States he lives in Texas
they're fighting in Texas Stadium every
Texan should come out stand up and put
their hands together now we're gonna go
through boxing history
Mikey Garcia's whole family is just
nothing but fighters I told y'all about
that I told you about that lineage when
it goes through fighters Mikey you gotta
see his fighting family the blood is
rich so he learned from a very young age
how to move how to saw how to dip out of
controller man and what you know what
you're gonna see is two men trying to
gain control on Saturday
Errol Spence is the first of his kind
and his family he's an anomaly he's an
exception to the rule he is a high level
fighter fighting in a manner that will
destroy certain opponents his
my key Garcia one of those certain
opponents my key Garcia has put together
a resume that's impeccable from the
outside looking in you might say Mikey
got this summed up baby I'm gonna tell
you one thing once a dog is let loose
inside of a fighter and that means you
know the ability to quit it's called dog
because when you go training you trying
to get the dog out of you that doubt
that dog
Mikey Garcia's fought cielito and then
that fight he had his nose broke
Mikey quitting a fight even though
there's an act like he did watch the
fight give me your opinion
Earl Spence on Saturday night will make
Mikey quit Earl Spence on Saturday night
will be Mikey bad his brother's going to
throw the towel in the ring because
mikey is not gonna give up mikey is
gonna try to gain control mikey has need
the big enough sharp enough or fast
enough or strong enough to keep Spence
off of him from round one Spence will go
in establishing the jab then dominating
to the body mikey has never had a body
that is a body of a well-conditioned
fighter he has always had a decent body
Mikey's had to fight his body Earl
Spence has an Olympians body he has an
Olympians mindset this is his belt do
you know how many Walter weights want
him out
Sprint's will destroy Garcia 9th and
10th round the fight is over does combat
talk with the king
catch you next week we have another bomb
burner
[Applause]
[Music]